I got into the pinchment of my rotator cop that they think was at least based on normal
exercise.
That's no fun.
Let's have for my daughter last weekend.
She long off the horse and landed wrong and heard her rotator cop.
Saw the ortho be ordered to MRI and my shoulder and arm when he feels with all my mobility,
maybe a picture.
Paid has been a 10 for the last seven days with sleepless nights.
Sorry about that.
I've had no choice to start predisone pack for 12 days.
As I tried everything else for the pain with the lock tried PT yesterday.
Paid was a bear.
Don't go to PT.
Don't let any physical doctor or chiropractor try to manipulate your shoulder.
It was just to get on here.
I thought it all set up last time when I listened to it.
You want it to heal.
So don't, don't do that.
Then bummed about taking supplements that predisone is, is a, is a, would be a blocker.
So, yeah, but you got to do what you got to do.
I would, I would also run.
Okay, I had this happen to be.
Gosh, it was about, you know, it was had to be like air nine years ago.
No.
I'm telling lies.
And I was in a sling for three weeks.
I literally, if I moved my arm totally out.
I got a shot.
I was taking a Tylenol.
I didn't understand.
I could buy a bottle of Tylenol and it lasts me about 10 years.
So I just don't take this stuff.
So this is before my cancer diagnosis.
And I heard it lifted weights or something like that.
And I was in pain.
Just horrible.
I was in a sling slept with a sling.
I could not move my arm was just my left shoulder.
And then, uh, uh, finally ran a program on the right called accelerated.
Healing.
It's in the, uh,
the folder called the normalizing frequency folder.
So the normalizing.
Sorry, I have to look at the key.
So it's in the normalizing frequency for a folder accelerated healing.
I'm going to say this is going to work for you.
Cause it's just, it's frequencies.
But I tell you, I did that one time.
Um, and that I literally forgot to take my, my, uh, Tylenol at three hours.
And it's like, it was like six hours later.
I didn't take my time.
I tried to talk.
Oh my gosh.
It's like, okay, it doesn't hurt.
I moved it.
But the sling is not hurting.
Not hurting.
Uh, I went home from work that day.
And I was literally afraid to take the, I still didn't take the sling off.
Because it's like, no way.
I'm not going to take it off.
This is going to send me through the road.
Literally, I did the accelerated healing.
I think three or four more times.
And my shoulder.
You know, he'll not, I'd ever had that.
Zinger paid anymore.
My pain went down to zero.
Well, I mean, I had some pain as I was trying to.
I had this stuck in a position for three weeks.
So it took some little bit of exercise to get it back to normal motion.
It took a few weeks, but it was, it was quite amazing.
Also think about the tens unit.
So whatever you get musculoskeletal pain like this.
A tens unit is a nice little addition.
You, I wouldn't necessarily do it right over a possible damaged ligament.
But I would do it where my pain is and it can really help with the pain.